hey guys today is the 18th of May my
name is just and here's what's been
happening in gaming first up today every
world of warcraft expansion is now free
as part of the main game including the
latest one world of three nor the
warlords of Draenor expansion saw a
price change to 10 bucks in april and
then disappeared completely from the
battlenet store it was later confirmed
by blizzard that this was because the
expansion is now free originally paying
for the expansion got you a character
boost to level 90 and it's not totally
clear if that's still the case as there
are conflicting reports while the
warcraft itself costs 20 bucks with a
fifteen dollar months two months
subscription fee which is discounted if
an extended subscription is purchased
along with Draenor the base game will
come bundled with the burning crusade
wrath of the lich king cataclysm and
mists of pandaria well the warcraft next
big expansion legion is jus on august 30
it will introduce the new demon hunter
class a new level cap of 110 as well as
new dungeons and raids square enix have
announced a bunch of their plans for e3
this year in a blog post the publisher
said games playable at its booth will
include Deus Ex mankind divided the
third episode of hitman just cause 3 new
land mech assault dlc star ocean and I
am setsuna also playable are some of the
crowdfunded games from the company's
Square Enix collective program well also
plan to host a live show where they will
make announcements and host developers
the publisher have also said that a
future blog post will include details on
other demos and sold bands to stay tuned
for some exciting Tomb Raider news
finally Warner Brothers have confirmed
that Batman Arkham Asylum and Arkham
City remasters are on their way to xbox
one and ps4 after a whole mess of leaks
Warner Brothers has confirmed that the
games will arrive on July 26 as part of
the Batman returned to Arkham bundle
which will cost 50 bucks the original
games were powered by Unreal Engine 3
but the remasters have been ported to
unreal engine wore a first for the
series Chinese company virtuous handled
the development having previously
co-developed heavy rains ps4 version and
contributed to uncharted for the bundle
will include the base games as well as
all game of the year extras and
downloadable content when a relative
said the remasters feature improved
graphics as well as upgraded models
environments lighting effects and shaded
it's worth noting that batman arkham
origins is not included in the package
as it was developed by WB games montreal
and not frosted it should let me know in
that comment section if you're keen to
revisit to Batman's adventures you can
also head to games but we've got stories
on GTA 5 sales and PlayStation Network
and later that is everything I've got P
today but do let me know what mattered
to you and I will see you again tomorrow